I see really something in common this
morning because comedy superstars Will
Ferrell Namie polar both actors were
featured performers on Saturday Night
Live they know Koston and now co-star in
the new movie the house they play parent
to make questionable financial decisions
to get their daughter through college
Ferrell and polar talk with each other
about the movie and other things they
have in kind
what do you sit here Amy thanks well
yeah give the password Andres a giant
looking at a bad man mmm yep this axe is
burning a hole in my pocket I'm Amy
Poehler
I'm here with Will Ferrell welcome to
CBS this morning something in common you
don't have enough money the Johansson's
had some trouble funding a college
education and in the film the house
opening June 30th says right here and
this this account we have four hundred
and one thousand dollars jackpot you
missed it
nope uh that says you have a 401k
account if you liquidate that right now
you'll have you know maybe five thousand
dollars how did you pay for college uh a
student loans I also received financial
aid a little bit of scholarship was it
an athletic scholarship yes it was okay
the smaller one for what sport um I was
on the equestrian team wow I got $200 a
year that's that blue I mean every
little bit helps tada
in the movie we try to keep our
homegrown cuz you know a secret from our
kids what do you think is an important
thing to keep from your kids well I
can't speak to anyone else on a general
sense about what they should keep from
their kids but for me I am doing a
pretty good job of keeping any sort of
knowledge above my second family
from my kids that's smart my wife Doreen
who lives in Dallas Texas hi oh hi
Doreen hey girl my three kids Cody
Cody and goobie two kids Thank You Cody
one's a girl one's a boy Oh
codeine codeine do you know
stranger-danger are their parenting
lessons to be learned here so I'm a
scary frat guy right okay
there's a lot of them mom is you notice
the take away nothing come milady come
come my lady you're my sugar pie honey
baby yeah nothing no lessons to be
learned
great have any of your kids inherited
your sense of humor well they're they've
all got a little glimmer in their eye
that my oldest boy had just revealed to
me through his friend how Magnus got out
of swimming by telling the coach that he
was having his period I thought that's
shocking
but that's kind of funny this happy hour
is from 4:00 to 6:00
do your kids think you're funny um
sometimes I think if I'm reading to them
I'm doing voices they think that's funny
sneaks up on that might sneak up but
I'll do that too and a lot of times I
get stopped with the voices let's get
back to the story
stop with the blind yeah like I
appreciate what you're trying to do but
you're taking away from the story yeah
don't make this about you yeah yeah I
just got one the other day I was like
mom please don't sing anymore to our
favorite songs though it's easy to
pretend I know young man
don't sing out loud I was like why I'm
sick I'm just nailing it yeah if I
wanted to give you advice as a Bostonian
I would remind you that just because
you're wicked smaht it doesn't mean you
better than me
we've both addressed college graduates
before I want the university to know
that I do not take this prestigious
honor lightly I've already instructed my
wife and my children from this point on
they have to address me as dr. ferral
there will be no exceptions give me your
best one-line commencement speech I
would say try your best but if it
doesn't work out you can always be a
substitute teacher period your best
piece of advice from SNL host Alec
Baldwin gave me advice once I don't
think I've only got seven eight nine
shows under my belt and he says and I
took it as a compliment he's like what
are you thinking about leaving the show
this is my first year I mean I know you
can't stay forever but I really like it
it's like cuz you can't stay here
forever because I think about your next
move how often does someone call you
Tina Fey I'm not very often you don't I
get more mistaken funnily enough for
Rachel Dratch Oh traction I get mistaken
a lot for each other because we are
short with big googly blue eyes
interesting um and when Dratch puts a
wig on she looks like my Nana huh uh
when did you realize you were funny oh
you told me
oh you've never been trying to be funny
this whole time oh I've been playing it
straight Oh
and it's not just well do this okay
let's just go to light now
yeah I'm gonna ask you the next one
[Music]
tiger mom or soccer mom oh you would
think I would just go to soccer right
away but it's so hot
soccer games are so hot so you can go
Tiger can I go um indoor air conditioned
Tiger air conditioned tire look in a
dome anchorman or fake news uh anchorman
all the way how about that that squirrel
can water-ski Oh Wonder Woman haven't
seen it can't wait don't see it go see
the house the house heard it's good the
house is the one woman of comedy
yes how does he do that guys and keep
his face straight while he's saying
something totally hilarious he's great
look forward to see about moving the
house and his wife's name is vivica he
doesn't have another wife just in case
anybody both of them